oui vous allez faire votre évolution
vous confirmez oui je pense votre
révolution oui je pense qu'il faut que
nous aussi nous nous bougions beaucoup
de choses parce que il y à une
aspiration à la participation
démocratique très fort chez ceux qui
veulent reconstruire la gauche un parti
communiste d'aujourd'hui il faut que
nous les associons c'est pour ça que
nous avons démarré le processus de notre
congrès différemment d'habitude la
direction publié un texte
on l'a on a décidé justement de
commencer par une consultation et
gameiro vous introduisez des mots non il
ya toujours eu de la démocratie mais on
s'y prend autrement pourquoi parce que
déjà il faut discuter il ya tellement de
choses à repenser à revoir il ya
beaucoup de travail à des défis énormes
on en a conscience
donc il faut un peu trier dans tout ça
par quoi on commence donc voilà des
questions qu'on a posés parcours sur
quoi au parc on commence alors on
s'aperçoit chez nous que par exemple les
questions de la révolution sociale mais
aussi de la lutte contre le coût du
capital de l'évasion fiscale est bien
revient très fort chez nous les
questions l'écologie viennent très fort
on va en parler ce qu'on va faire des
assises communiste pour l'écologie en
2018 avant notre congrès pour le
préparer jacky qui est très très
largement alimentée par jean luc
mélenchon oui mais tant mieux tant mieux
plus il ya de gens qui se mêlent des
grands sujets de la société moi ça ne me
pose pas de ça ne pose pas de problème
alors est ce que la vraie révolution du
parti communiste sera le 12 à bord
donnerait le mot communiste
non je ne crois pas parce que la
question qui nous est posée sur le mot
communisme n'est pas celle là parce que
nous croyons à cette idée d'ailleurs
l'idée du commun qui est à la racine de
notre engagement est une idée qui
reprend de la vigueur singulièrement
dans les jeunes générations aujourd'hui
parce qu'il ya des enjeux aussi
écologique et tout le monde voit bien
qu'il faut plutôt traiter les grands
enjeux du monde comme des biens communs
plutôt que dans la jungle de la
concurrence donc nos idées peuvent
reprendre de l'espace mais évidemment
faut que nous soyons nous identifier à
ses idées modernes qui sont les nôtres
dans l'antenne de m6 règle non et donc
parfois il ya des
il ya des ddd chose du passé qui pèse
lourd dans notre image trop lourd dans
notre image
donc on a besoin de modifier cette image
là mais ne signifie pas abandonner le
nom le nom communiste non séparément
dans les consultations il est est ce que
vous aviez l'air d'être bien
bon alors la question avant les jo je
serai bien ce qui vient très fortement
dans la consultation qu'on fait c'est ne
pas abandonner le mot communisme mais
travailler très profondément sur notre
image dans la société vous